Liz Cheney
is a threat
she's saying
that if Donald Trump is the nominee
in 2024 for the Republicans she
she might leave the Republican Party
I think that Donald Trump is
he's the only president in American
history who refused to guarantee a
peaceful transition to power and so
um now the fact that my party has
refused
in the months since then to stand up to
him I think does tell you how sick the
party is I'm gonna make sure Donald
Trump from the Jefferson can make sure
he's not the nominee and if he is a
nominee I won't be a Republican
okay
thank you
Liz Cheney out of the Republican party
don't threaten me with a good time
Liz Cheney of course is not a republican
she might pretend to be a republican she
might when she goes on to all of the
Democrat news networks to attack the
Republicans she might put an R next to
her name and but she was first of all
she was kicked out of her own State
party the Wyoming Republican party
booted her out but let's say she she
identifies as a republican for practical
purposes she is not a Republican
and why not I don't want to play
psychobabble I don't want to say it's
because of her Pride I don't want to say
it's because she got Trump derangement
syndrome because Donald Trump attacked
her and attacked her father and some of
the administrations she worked for I I'm
I don't know why Liz Cheney is doing
this but it is simply a fact she is for
all intents and purposes a Democrat she
voted for Joe Biden last time and that's
simply unacceptable that's funny we
talked about this a little bit yesterday
on the show
Joe Biden sent his Jack booted Thug FBI
agents to the home of a pro-life author
and Advocate a man who peacefully
demonstrates outside of abortion clinics
and he sent these jack-booted FBI thugs
to point their rifles at this man and
his family and his seven children and
terrorize the family and it's just it's
it's just the latest
acceleration of an attack by the Biden
Administration on Christians on
conservatives on pro-lifers in
particular the Biden Administration
which
describes parents who don't want their
kids to be taught critical race Theory
and weird sex stuff in school as a
domestic extremist threat basically
calling these people terrorists the
Biden Administration don't forget Joe
Biden back in the Obama Administration
that Administration sued nuns because
the nuns didn't want to kill little
babies and go along with the left's
radical sexual Revolution agenda Joe
Biden who refers to half the country
refers to you as fast semi-fashion
chests and extreme threats to our
democracy Joe Biden who is hiring up 87
000 IRS agents to attack you Joe Biden
who time and time again
is attacking conservatives now imposing
abortion despite the Court's ruling in
Dobbs imposing abortion in in pro-life
States okay it is not acceptable Joe
Biden who is now imposing
child transgenderism
through his Federal bureaucracy
castrating little kids Joe Biden who's
hiring overt satanists guys who actually
have pentagrams on their chest okay it's
not acceptable to defend this stuff to
say nothing of the lawlessness the open
borders that the
the attacks on pretty much every
American way of life it's not defensible
I don't want to hear oh Liz Cheney she's
just got a different point of view oh
well you know it's sort of reasonable
reasonable Minds can disagree sure but
reasonable Minds cannot support Joe
Biden okay Joe Biden says we're in a war
for the soul of our nation and he allies
himself with with actual satanists and
actively promotes castrating little kids
and putting them on Gross sex hormones
and killing a bunch of other little kids
and and keeping the Border open and
flooding the country with foreigners and
suppressing our political rights and
censoring us and and throwing grannies
who showed up to the Capitol Rotana and
into into solitary confinement meanwhile
encouraging BLM and antifa to Riot and
kill people I just don't want to hear it
I just don't want to hear it yeah we are
in a soul a battle for the soul of our
nation
and you've got to pick a side there is
no neutrality there is no reasonable
Minds disagree here okay and Liz Cheney
has said and and this the squishes that
she stands for there aren't very many of
them but some people
are saying yeah I'll vote for Joe Biden
when the going gets tough
okay fine but then you're not you know
you're not a republican it's not
reasonable and I have absolutely no
respect for the woman
it's just like we were talking about
those FBI agents yesterday I tried to
distinguish between the good the good
FBI agents who do good work and who
sometimes have to follow bad orders and
the corrupt Biden officials who are
running the FBI and the doj but
sometimes you can't let the agents off
the hook and when those agents got the
call to go raid the home of the
pro-lifer and his and his wife and his
seven kids for no reason
uh then I don't let those agents off the
hook I I hold them personally morally
responsible for what they're doing okay
and I think that they're they should be
greatly ashamed and they should
apologize and they should resign and
they should refuse the order
and I don't want to hear oh well you
know it was a very confusing time it's
very complicated like green Jean Pierre
says it's not that complicated
but Ronald Reagan said that the path
forward sometimes is simple not easy
necessarily but simple that there's
really no difference between a left and
a right only an up or a down well pick a
side pick a side you know the rest of
the show is continuing now you do not
want to miss it we are going to be
joined by my friend
the great David Limbaugh if you are not
a member click a link in the description
and join us we'll see you over there
[Music]
[Music]